bonjour pierre tattevin merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a entendu un olivier ferrand dans
une interview accordée au jdd assure que
le vaccin contre le coc u19 va sauver
beaucoup de vies
comment vous accueillez vous ce début de
campagne
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une très
bonne nouvelle on a bien vu qu'avec
toutes les mesures qu'on essayait de
mettre en place au cours de l'année 2020
on a quand même eu à subir des vagues
terribles notamment la deuxième alors
qu'on avait tout ce qu'il fallait comme
masqués comme test on n'a pas vraiment
traitement efficace est par contre les
données sur le vaccin sont très très
encourageante et je pense qu'il a raison
ça va sauver beaucoup de vies si on
arrive à vacciner les personnes fragiles
comme on va commencer aujourd'hui donc
les très bonnes nouvelles on l'a vu dans
un dernier sondage 60% des français ne
serait pas forcément favorable à l'idée
de se faire vacciner
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce chiffre
parce que ça fait quand même plus plus
d'un français sur deux oui on part avec
un gros déficit un sabre à faire une
dizaine d'années qu'on est un des pays
qui émet le plus de doutes sur le
bénéfice risque des vaccins
c'est celle fruits notamment un gros
travail de sape des lobbys anti
vaccinales qui fait qui fait du mal et
là c'est d'autant plus mal venue que
c'est un vaccin sur lequel les études
ont été très rigoureux ça a été évalué
par d'état d'âge ans de différents pays
des gens indépendants
les résultats sont vraiment très beau
donc il va falloir qu'on communique
mieux vous comme nous et d'ailleurs ça
va être un travail pour les journalistes
aussi pour mieux expliquer les bénéfices
est ce que vous comprenez justement
c'est 60% qui serait assez réticent
justement à l'idée de ceux de se faire
vacciner est ce que vous comprenez leur
argument votre micro trottoir et un
début de séance était très bien fait
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il ya des gens
qui l ont décidé que non qui ont jamais
voulu se faire vacciner contre rien et
c'est une petite proportion est ensuite
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
hésitants qui attendent de voir parce
que le vaccin a été développé très vite
c'est sûr et cette partie de la
population devrait être progressivement
rassuré quand ils vont voir que les gens
vont miser pas devons avoir moins de 2,4
qu'ovide beaucoup moins de décès et que
les effets indésirables qui sont
habituelles avec beaucoup de vaccins
sont finalement transitoire est plutôt
mineures
donc j'espère que avec le temps les gens
vont avoir moins d'inquiétude et vont
voir que même si l'ue axe 1 a été
développé vite il est quand même
vraiment bénéfique et les effets
indésirables sont minimes
alors tout à l'heure vous parliez
d'études récentes 1 le ministre de la
santé parlait quant à ce vaccin de
risque extrêmement faible
notamment à propos des des réactions
allergiques est ce qu on a une idée
aujourd'hui elle peut être un petit peu
plus précis de potentiels effets
secondaires sur sur ce vaccin
ce qu'on sait certainement c'est que
c'est rare parce que dans la grande
étude qui a permis la commercialisation
du premier vaccin qu'on va avoir ils ont
avec le quarante mille personnes y en a
vingt mille coups reçus le vaccin il ya
eu aucun effet indésirable grave
après c'est quand on aura matinée des
millions de personnes dans les
différents pays qu'on sera plus il ya
peut-être un risque d'effet allergique
grave j'ai peut-être personnes vaccinées
sur un million ou quelque chose comme ça
et ça on le saura après avoir commencé
les campagnes mais ça restera néanmoins
très bénéfique pour la plupart des gens
alors aujourd'hui la stratégie du
gouvernement commençant cette campagne
qui commence aujourd'hui avec tout
d'abord les ehpad 1 le personnel de plus
de 65 ans et puis les pensionnaires des
ehpad ensuite les personnes à risque et
enfin le grand public est ce que cette
stratégie vous paraît la bonne il
fallait commencer par les gens les plus
à risque parce que c'est pas s'épanouir
et un peu plus jeunes qui risquent le
plus de mourir de cette maladie c'est
les gens pour qui on commence la
baptisation schiste le bénéfice est
vraiment majeurs et après une fois que
la campagne sera lancée qu on aura mieux
du côté opérationnel qu'on sera mieux
comment faire on pourra étendre
progressivement mais commencer par les
gens qui sont les plus à risque de
mourir du virus est tout à fait logique
alors olivier vers on espère que le
vaccin après vienne
non seulement les formes graves de la
maladie de la maladie pardon mais aussi
les transmission du virus
nous saurons dans les prochains moins
combien de tours devons nous attendre
avant de savoir si le vaccin sera sûre
efficace sur les nouvelles transmissions
il faut bien effectivement attendre
encore quelques mois parce que c'était
pas les critères regarder au début ils
ont vraiment regarder si le bac ça a été
bénéfique pour les gens c'est à dire si
ça les éviter leur évitait de cernier
maladie mais je pense que si dans trois
mois les premiers pays vacciner comme le
royaume-uni ou les etats-unis ont une
grande chute des nouveaux cas dans les
populations vaccinées on pourra dire que
non seulement ça évite les maladies mais
que ça évite aussi la transmission et on
pourra souffler et préparer la suite une
vie sans qu'ovide peut être un merci
beaucoup pertes avant d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france je rappelle
que vous êtes et chef du service
d'infectiologie au chu de rennes et
président de la société de pathologie
infectieuse de à la langue française
merci beaucoup